- Our next guest is a very funny woman
that you've seen in HBO's "Insecure."
she's got a book out now,
it's called "Bamboozled by Jesus:
How God Tricked Me Into
the Life of My Dreams.
(laughing)
The best title.
Please, everybody welcome ,Yvonne Orji!
(clapping)
(audience cheering)
(upbeat pop music)
- I did this for you!
- Gosh, you look- this
might be my favorite outfit
that anyone's ever worn.
The hair, the earrings,
the lipstick, oh my God.
- It's a thing.
- You look fabulous!
- I did it for you, ma'am!
- Oh my God.
- I kind of match the color scheme.
- Yes, you're so colorful, I love it.
- Thank you.
- Oh my God. Yeah you just walked out
and I'm just jealous.
It's nice to meet you!
- It's a- I am a huge fan.
- Oh- even if you're lying- thank you.
- No, ut I'm not, though because I had the
Miseducation of Lauren
Hill room with the karaoke
background, I may or may
not have been jamming out
to (sings) since you've been gone!
(laughter)
- And I am not a singer whatsoever.
- You should've put on her record.
That's like one of my favorites.
That's why it's that room.
- That's why it's that room?
- Yeah, those are all
like my favorite records-
- Oh I saw the Alanis
Morrissette "Jagged Little Pill"
- Yes.
- Oh that was-
- I got some Annie Lennox
in there, so yeah, yeah.
- Remember those Columbia House stickers?
- Yes.
- That was- so Columbia House was a thing
you could mail stickers and
they would send you CDs.
(laughter)
- And you would get CDs.
- Google it.
- So CDs were um-
(laughter)
- Alanis Morissette was one
of my first CDs I ever got.
- Me too.
- Oh my gosh, Jagged
Little Pill, so classic.
- I was like "she's saying
it all, and I'm in."
- Yes.
- But I'm only allowed to
sing songs where I yell,
cause I don't sing,
because if I could sing,
I would be a stripper.
(laughter)
- Did you say "if I could
sing id be a stripper"?
- God could not trust
me with a singing voice,
like He knows ho He can trust,
because I would be that
person like "how you doing?"
"yeah yeah. Drop it low"
"Chocolate Testimony"
would be my stripper name.
- "Chocolate Testimony"?
- I had the whole thing planned out,
but that's why God was like-
- You have got to make that show. (laughs)
- He keeps me humble. Like
two things I cannot have-
I can't have 6 pack abs, cause, again,
I would wear pasties to
church and I just don't think
that that's appropriate.
- I think that God would frown.
- I think He'd be like
"Daughter, what are we doing?"
So He keeps me humble
with like a humble pouch
and like a (clicks).
- I always say that about Salma Hayak.
I was like, when I'd
see Salma Hayak I'm like
"God didn't allow me to look
that good for a reason."
I would be just walking around naked.
Yup, she's so beautiful.
- You have to know your limitations
and He knew them before.
- He knew.
- He knew. Girl, please.
- You are so funny. Wait but
before you got "Insecure"
on HBO, I heard that you
were a wedding emcee,
which is awesome.
- Yes. I was the ultimate
hype woman at every event.
I did weddings, birthdays, baby showers.
- Your personality is perfect for it.
- Bless you, hello. Are we best friends
because all this love that
you're giving me right now
like I'm a sunflower, I'm
blooming, I'm in full bloom.
- Full bloom.
- Yes.
- What was it like, though?
- (exhales)
- Because brides can be crazy.
- Well, it's not really so much
the brides. The bridesmaids.
- Oh, really?
- Girl. Hosting weddings kind
of turned me off to weddings
for a long time because you
see how the sausage is made.
So, yes the brides can
be a little bit like
"This is what I want"
but then the bridesmaids
sometimes are a little like
low-key haters. Like they are!
- On the bride?
- Because it's not their day,
like especially the single
ones, like it's not their day.
So it's like "oh, but I want to do this"
it's like "boo boo, I
just need you to line up
and walk out when I say
walk. Like real talk,
I just don't any lip.
Just follow me, here!"
And I'm just like "You're
not paying my check.
You're not cutting my check
so just do what I say."
- Just get in the line.
- "I got orders from the
woman in white, okay?"
- Oh my God. (laughs) That's horrible.
Having bridesmaids like that.
- Sometimes I want to
send a thank you note,
like "thank you for having
me to host your wedding,
also, check your friends, girl."
- "Also, the redhead? Don't trust her."
- "Also, everybody's not for you."
- "Every friendship has a season."
- "And this one has come to an end."
- But I want to talk about your new book,
it's called "Bamboozled by Jesus"
so why is it called that?
It's an amazing title.
- Because girl, first of
all, the fact that I am
sitting on this couch, this
is a big bamboozling moment
because I was supposed to
be a doctor, I really was.
My last name is "Orji" so
that wasn't gonna work.
"Paging Dr. Orji to gynecology"?
I was like that's a set
up. Stop playing. Stop it.
And I also don't like blood
so I don't know how this
is gonna work out.
- I love you so much.
- And so, but I didn't
know what else to do,
so I literally was doing the thing.
I went to college, I
have a degree in biology,
and all of the things, and
then, when I was getting
my master's in public
health, I entered a pageant
and God told me to do
comedy, and I was like
"Mm, You don't know."
Because I was like "that
makes no sense. I'm not funny.
I've never done stand-up."
- You're one of the
funniest people who has ever
been in my presence.
I'm so happy right now.
- Thank you! But I
didn't know that in 2006.
I literally was just trying to figure out
how not to be a doctor
and how not to get out of
my parents' will, you know what I mean?
Like, this is how much I
was so afraid to tell them
that I didn't want to go to med school.
- Oh no.
- I got a master's degree
and then I went to live
in war-torn Liberia, yes,
because I was just evading
the reality of "I don't
want to do this thing that
you guys really thought I would do."
- I think it's amazing that
you're writing this though,
and people will be able to
relate and you're hilarious.
- Thank you.
- You're like such a
light, and you're so funny,
and you've just completely
turned my mood around.
You're just so funny.
- You're awesome! But
that was the whole thing,
I wanted to write a book where
you could have faith and fun.
Because people, especially
in Hollywood, they're like
"How are you able to be
successful in Hollywood
and still love Jesus?"
I was like "I didn't
know I had to choose."
Like when did- I didn't
know it was a platter
- My Jesus is fun as
hell. Oh, that's funny.
Ironic. "fun as hell"
(laughter)
- I was like "It's a buffet"
so I crack jokes in the book,
I talk about my love for
Cardi B and DMX, and my love
for Luke 5:25, you know?
Whatever! All things
work together for good.
You like what I did there?
(laughter)
- That was awesome. I love
that, though. I think it's
an important message, too,
and not everybody's saying it.
I think that's really important.
Everybody, Yvonne's book is
called "Bamboozled by Jesus"
it's out now. You gotta check it out.